soir chantal accord causse merci d'être
avec nous en direct de rio de janeiro la
base des ministres de la santé continue
donc en pleine pandémie poste
stratégique mais instable
ils ne disent pas ce que veut entendre
le président écoute et nous sommes nous
en sommes à notre quatrième ministre de
la santé qui donne des des messages
complètement contradictoires à ce que la
communauté scientifique
emre aimerait entendre on aimerait
exécuter un la communauté scientifique
est aujourd'hui pour certains médecins
qui sont pour le port du masque pour le
look down est contrôlée traitement
précoce
elles sont menacées incertains sont
menacés de mort les les disons que ce
sont les nids les grands affectueux
infectiologues qui que l'on voit à la
télévision de façon régulière cela son
sont menacés malheureusement et la
communauté scientifique
on est complètement en fait je dire il
n'y en a plus beaucoup de 2,2 de recours
1 par rapport à les scientifiques ont
toujours été plus scientifique politique
moi je me place aussi dans ceux d'un de
ceux dans ce lot et je dois dire que
c'est difficile pour nous tous de nous
immiscer dans la politique
alors comment vous accueillez justement
vous les scientifiques les médecins de
la nomination de marcelo et hérault gard
il est président de la société
brésilienne de cardiologie donc médecin
lui-même
est-ce que c'est plutôt un bon signal
qui vous est envoyé or malheureusement
je suis né je n'ai pas cette impression
j'ai l'impression qu'il va exécuter le
en fait le va exécuter le programme du
gouvernement ça m'étonnerait qu'ils
puisqu'il est un des 1 degré de liberté
pour pour agir
il représentait la communauté
scientifique alors pourtant ban soon as
roi a tout de même récemment changé de
discours concernant la vaccination
admettant qu'elles étaient
indispensables vous pensez pas que la
stratégie de ce nouveau ministre
justement va se concentrer là dessus sur
cette campagne de vaccination au brésil
était un peu on peut espérer puisque
vous venez de montrer que des vaccins
spoutnik i ne sont encore pas agréé par
notre food and drug administration' qui
ont été achetés ici on fabrique le
oxford on fabrique le cornac peut-être
pas assez rapidement je l'espère
honnêtement je pense que il ya eu des
événements politiques ici de
l'opposition qui ont fait que le
gouvernement fédéral a changé son fusil
d épaule un est donc maintenant le
discours a changé pour pour combien de
temps et non dans quelle ampleur
je ne sais pas vous disiez que sportive
et attend encore les validations de vos
autorités
c'est un temps anormalement long
ça c'est la normalité non je pense qu'il
n'y a pas eu encore parce que les pour
les autres vaccins il ya une demande
urgente c'est pas une demande de
standards c'est une demande de
d'enregistrement urgentes qui auront les
vaccins comme le corona vaquer le une
deux le vaccin d'astrazeneca ou d
enregistrer très rapidement et en fait
pour une utilisation d'urgence et
l'astra zeneca maintenant une
enregistrement standard je pense que le
combat va bientôt le le spoutnik je
crois qu'il n'y a pas encore eu de
demande donc pourquoi ils sont
enregistrés il faut qu'il y ait une
demande il faut qu'ils fournissent des
tas de documents de papier enfin bref il
ya une procédure
donc c'est en cours vous dites la
vaccination a débuté
on commence à en sentir les effets au
brésil on le rappelle le brésil qui
était vraiment dans une situation
dramatique et qu'il est certainement au
corps non nous sommes dans une situation
très difficile parce que nous avons ce
variant paix delà de l'amazonie qui est
qui et qui est très éthique qui
contamine et qui est beaucoup plus qu
est beaucoup plus contagieux qui est
beaucoup plus mortel en fait imaginer
l'état de sang parle où nous avons dix
mille lits de cti rendu pense que c'est
que des milliers de ce pays qui sont
tous occupés et les taxes en parle est
en train de monter des hôpitaux de
campagne
à rio de janeiro nous avons 5 min à peu
près de deux unités de soins quand je
dis utilise et l'unité de soins
intensifs
ainsi dix c'est beaucoup par rapport à
d'autres pays et ils sont ils sont
occupés à 80% à rio et pour une fois on
peut dire que le brésil tout entier est
et dépasser plusieurs dons et et je dire
à un pourcentage d'occupation dénis très
important alors que jusqu'à maintenant
ça a été disparates secteur médical
co c'est une question qu'on se pose
depuis la france la situation était très
difficile on le sait au brésil on a tous
vu ces images dramatiques avec le
variant avec le kobe de classique est ce
qu'avec ce variant que vous évoquez
c'est encore pire si on peut dire je
pense que oui parce que en fait c'est
vrai que nous avons vacciné quand même
la population jusqu'à 75 60 par là cette
semaine où on vaccine les 60 70 ans et
71 ans d'accord donc comme partout la
maladie rajeunie et le fait qu'elle
rajeunissent les personnes qui sont en
unité de soins intensifs restent plus
longtemps
ce sont des personnes qui résistent plus
longtemps heureusement quand on arrive à
soigner qu'on arrive à sortir de dures
du tableau critique mais donc ce sont
des gens qui restent plus de trois
semaines en unité de soins intensifs
merci chantal torck aux médecins
généralistes à rio de janeiro de vent
étaient avec nous pour nous évoquer la
situation au brésil